the reason for that is that hbo has a
new show
the new show is called transhood here's
the description
filmed over five years in kansas city
trans hood
chronicles the lives of four young
people
aged 15 okay 12
7 and 4
and their families as they navigate
growing up
transgender in america's heartland
four years old transgender
i almost was not going to even play this
clip on the show because it's so
disturbing and these degenerates who
filmed it
and who participated in it these adults
should be in prison
but it's on hbo it's out there the clip
has gone viral and i suppose
just like putting up images of a crime
are helpful to nabbing the perpetrators
i think
we should probably publicize this clip
that's already out there
so that we can bring this to the public
forefront and so that laws can be passed
to make this
illegal take a listen good morning
today we choose to recognize honor love
and celebrate
anyone here who would claim their
identity publicly as lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer or
questioning intersex pansexual asexual
or any category that i've left out
this is phoenix
phoenix is looks like four years old
looks like a little guy do you wanna
tell everyone if you're a boy or a girl
[Music]
phoenix would like you to know that
she's a girl and she prefers she
and her pronouns
[Music]
may you be well safe and whole
we honor you exactly as you are
this is so wrong on
every single level and every adult
in that room first of all a law should
be passed against this if you can't
use current child abuse laws you should
create a new law against whatever this
is you should prosecute every single
person in this room every adult
you should throw them in prison and you
should throw away the key
that's it little river
does not want to tell people that this
little boy does not want to tell
people that he's a little girl he
manifestly does not
he says he's too shiny he leaves he
walks away and then his
sociopath mother takes the microphone
and says my
little boy is a little girl and then
these perverts all in a
in a what is obviously a religious
ceremony
a leftist religious ceremony
tell the little boy that he's a little
girl and they give him a little flower
now this is a religion right there
actually is a term for this which is
called gnostic dualism
it's a heresy that i thought was snuffed
out in the west
over a thousand years ago and it
apparently wasn't it's the idea that
uh your physical body has nothing to do
with your true self your true self which
is purely metaphysical so
your body can be entirely male for
instance but your true metaphysical self
is female in some way
it's a it's a it's a ridiculous religion
but it is a religious view
these sickos are forcing that religious
view on these children
and convincing them
and confusing them into believing that
little boys are little girls and little
girls or little boys
and seriously inflicting psychological
damage on them
and there are some people in in this
country there's some people
in the conservative movement who look at
this
and say that it is a blessing of liberty
i kid you not
people who they call themselves
libertarians but i don't
i wouldn't call them libertarians
because i think that's offensive to
libertarian to actual libertarianism
which i'm not a libertarian myself but i
this is something even
more shallow and degraded to say that oh
yes
thomas jefferson and george washington
would love
a bunch of adults abusing little
children and convincing little boys that
they're little girls
that's what they meant when they
described the blessings of liberty that
is not what they meant
when they described the blessings of
liberty and there's a
real issue on the right that we need to
deal with and snuff out
which is this mistaken belief that we
are not allowed to have any views
on moral matters we're not allowed to
have any and we're certainly not allowed
to enforce any views
because you can't legislate morality or
some other bumper slogan nonsense
of course you can not only can you
legislate morality you
necessarily legislate morality all laws
legislate morality from laws about the
death penalty down to parking tickets
all laws weigh in on moral questions
and come to moral conclusions and
enforce those moral conclusions
on the the country on the people
and it's in a way it's the right's fault
that we got this
the left are the aggressors so i don't
want to i don't want to victim blame
here you know
the real victims are the kids but it is
in a way conservative's fault
because what we said is when we were
approached by this radical leftism
which basically goes under the name of
political correctness we were approached
by this a completely new standard
a moral standard a religious standard a
standard of speech a standard of
behavior
a standard that said i'm going to have
drag queen story hour and twerk in front
of four-year-old kids i'm gonna have men
put on dresses and twerk in front of
four-year-old kids and i'm gonna
convince four-year-old kids that their
the little boys are little girls
when we were confronted with that
instead of pushing back and saying no
that's wrong
it's morally wrong it's physically
factually wrong
and we're not going to tolerate that
what we said is well
you know look you have your standard and
we have our standards
and there's no way that we can possibly
discern between the two
how there's no way to discern between
good and bad there's no way to
discern between things that lead to
human flourishing and things that lead
to human degradation there's no way to
discern
so we're just going to throw up our
hands and say you do you and and we do
it all in the name of say free speech
for instance
a lot of people are defending this child
abuse on the on the grounds of free
speech
child abuse is not free speech and in in
a way it's our fault
because for a long time maybe two
decades now
conservatives right-wingers have taken
this very shallow and inaccurate reading
of what free speech means in the
american tradition
to suggest that it means you can say
anything at all anything whatsoever that
is not true
that has never been true and
conservatives have not believed that
except for the past 15 or 20 years or so
there have been whole swaths of speech
that have been illegal in america from
the very beginning and nobody's
disagreed
sedition uh threats fighting words
fraud all all manner of speech
obscenity obviously obscenity has been
illegal from the very beginning we don't
enforce
it very much anymore but it is this is
obscene this is worse than obscene this
is abusive
and if there's nothing hypocritical
hypocritical rather about conservatives
calling that out
and the longer we cowardly in a cowardly
way
stand back throw up our hands and say
well i don't i can't criticize what
you're doing to those kids because then
look if i criticize you for transiting
the kids
you might criticize me for taking my
kids to church
okay but one of those things is good and
one of those things is evil
and we can discern we have rational
faculties
there is there is objective truth i know
that's unfashionable to say
we have faculties of reason that's also
unfashionable to say
and we can discern not always perfectly
but pretty well
between what is good and what is evil
using those faculties of reason
and we can enforce those views in the
political sphere that's what politics is
for
our founding fathers sure would have
understood that and i can't believe
that we are permitting this right now
that should be illegal we should not
ever ever permit that in this country
hbo should be boycotted that this movie
should be
taken off of the air and the the people
who not only produce the movie forget
that for a second these parents
should be prosecuted i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you